bienvenue dans le flambeau les
aventuriers de chupacabra les deux viol
a avoué partir tout de suite parce que
je choisirai pas ce soir même poussé
dans cette aventure où tout est possible
je suis partout
un seul de ses 14 aventurier et
succèdera à lionel qui a remporté
50 euros une somme folle - de picciotto
totaux de ce top marques qu'est ce que
vous faites là je sais pas vous fait
danser
bienvenue sur cette île de tupac à moi
vous allez devoir survivre pendant 38
jours sans rien vous êtes sûr que c'est
là parce que ya pas de vide à la
malterie on doit te construire nous
mêmes tout construire avec roanne nos
mains peut-être
vont dépasser la fin on crève la dalle
il n'y a pas de déjouer l'ennemi de
dîners quoi
la fatigue a bien dormi mettons bien oui
les trahisons évidemment que je les
travaille on va te contredire ce soir
mais non point en gros tu es pour
l'instant draghi
ou alors
oh [ __ ] c'est aux sauvegardes seul de
ses 14 aventuriers succèdera à lionel
qui a remporté les 450 euros une somme
folle rien n'empêchera gagné 450 euros
la guerre est fait que commencer j'ai
envie de faire partie de cette aventure
humaine tétouan mât ne ménageant aucun
secret pour moi c'est la bonne humeur
qui sera larmes qui me font à gagner
ce que tu viens tu
[Musique]
à
frolon fait vomir c'est le seul moyen de
faire du poids rapidement au
c'est ça ce qu'on appelle le multiverse